>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
SPECIAL EDITION OF TUCKER
CARLSON.
I'M WILL KANE IN FORT TUCKER.
HERE IS STAT THAT PUTS THE
COUNTRY'S COLLAPSE INTO
PERSPECTIVE.
MAY BE MORE THAN ANY OTHER, THE
DOW JONES JUST RECORDED ITS
EIGHTH STRAIGHT WEEKLY LOSS.
THE LAST TIME THAT HAPPENED WAS
ALL THE WAY BACK IN 1932 AROUND
THE HEIGHT OF THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
BUT RIGHT NOW, A LOT OF
AMERICANS OUR WONDERING HOW DID
WE GET HERE SO QUICKLY?
JUST A YEAR IN A HALF INTO JOE
BIDEN?
IT HAS BEEN A RAPID DECLINE.
IF YOU GET A MOMENT THIS WEEKEND
, WHOLE UP THE JOE BIDEN
INAUGURAL ADDRESS.
WE CAN BACK IT'S REMARKABLE.
NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT'S IN THE
SPEECH, BUT BECAUSE OF WHAT IS
MISSING FROM THE SPEECH.
YOU WANT HEAR A SINGLE MENTION
OF THE ISSUES AMERICANS ARE MOS
CONCERNED ABOUT.
NOTHING ON INFLATION, POVERTY,
GAS PRICES, THE STOCK MARKET,
NOTHING ON GOVERNMENT SPENDING
COMING ENERGY INDEPENDENCE,
FENTANYL OVERDOSES, AND NOTHING
ON BORDER SECURITY.
THERE ISN'T A SINGLE MENTION OF
POLICY IN THE ENTIRE ADDRESS
MARRIED INSTEAD HE TALKED ABOUT
HIMSELF.
HE COMPARED HIMSELF TO ABRAHAM
LINCOLN ISSUING THE EMANCIPATIO
PROCLAMATION.
HE TOLD US ONLY JOE BIDEN COULD
UNITE AMERICA, TO SAVE US FROM
QUOTE BITTERNESS AND FURY.
>> TODAY ON THIS JANUARY DAY, M
POSTAL IS IN THIS, BRINGING
AMERICAN TOGETHER, AND UNITING
OUR PEOPLE, UNITING OUR NATION.
I ASK EVERY AMERICAN TO JOIN ME
IN THIS CAUSE.
WE COULD JOIN FORCES.
STOP THAT THE SHOUTING AND LOWE
THE TEMPERATURE.
WITHOUT THAT, THERE IS ONLY
BITTERNESS AND PURÉE.
LET'S START AFRESH.
>> I THINK WE CAN ANNOUNCE THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS FINALLY SUCCEEDED
IN UNIFYING THE COUNTRY.
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
IN THE POLLING, IT IS VERY CLEAR
.
ACCORDING TO A CNN SURVEY FROM
THIS WEEK, ONLY 40 PERCENT OF
AMERICANS APPROVE OF JOE BIDEN'
JOB PERFORMANCE, THAT'S WORSE
THAN JIMMY CARTER AT THE SAME
POINT IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
65 PERCENT OF AMERICANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THE COUNTRY AND 21 PERCENT ARE
FLAT OUT SCARED.
JUST 14 PERCENT ARE EXCITED OR
OPTIMISTIC AND I WOULD LOVE TO
MEET THAT 14 PERCENT.
IN NBC NEWS PAUL CAME UP WITH
SIMILAR NUMBERS 39 PERCENT OF
AMERICANS ACCORDING TO NBC
APPROVE OF JOE BIDEN'S
PERFORMANCE, 60 TO PERCENT
DISAPPROVE OF HIS HANDLING OF
THE ECONOMY.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE ALSO WORSE
THAN JIMMY CARTER'S.
AMITY 1 PERCENT OF AMERICANS, 7
DISAPPROVE OF THE JOE HANDLING
OF THE COST-OF-LIVING 58 UPSET
WITH HIS BORDER POLICIES, AND
LISTEN TO THIS, ANOTHER NEW POL
FROM QUINNIPIAC FOUND JOE BIDEN
HAS A 26 PERCENT APPROVAL RATIN
AMONG HISPANICS, IT'S HIS LOWES
AMONG ANY DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP.
THAT'S A FLOOD OF NUMBERS COMIN
AT YOU.
BAD AS THOSE NUMBERS ARE, THERE
IS EVIDENCE THEY COULD BE
OVERESTIMATING THE JOE BIDEN
POPULARITY.
OF POLITICAL SCIENCE EDDIES OF
HER, LOOKED AT A RECENT POLL BY
MARIST IN THE POLL FOUND THAT
JOE BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING IS
39 PERCENT, THAT'S IN LINE WITH
WHAT WE SAW FROM THE OTHER, BUT
THE INSTITUTE WILL REPORTED THA
THE POPULARITY WAS MUCH HIGHER.
IN FACT A MOST 50 PERCENT AMONG
BABY BOOMERS.
CAN THAT BE RIGHT?
THEY DID SOME NUMBER CRUNCHING
AND FOUND 50 TO PERCENT OF
PEOPLE OVER 65, THEY VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP IN 2020, AND THE
INSTITUTE POLL FOUND THAT 2
PERCENT, JUST 2 PERCENT OF
PEOPLE THAT SUPPORTED DONALD
TRUMP IN 2020 NOW HAVE SHIFTED
TO HAVING A FAVORABLE OF JOE
BIDEN SO WHERE IS THIS NEW
SUPPORT FOR JOE BIDEN AMONG BAB
BOOMERS AND THE SILENT
GENERATION?
IT JUST DOESN'T ADD UP.
HERE IS THE POINT, AT THE END O
ALL OF THIS ARITHMETIC, THE
POLLS COULD BE OVERSTATING THE
POPULARITY AMONG OLDER AMERICANS
, AND THAT MAY BE DUE
TO A SAMPLING ERROR, IF THAT'S
THE CASE, JOE BIDEN IS LOWER
THAN 39 PERCENT.
THAT WOULD EXPLAIN WHITE NO ONE
IN THE MEDIA, NOT EVEN CNN IS
BOTHERING TO DEFEND JOE BIDEN
ANYMORE.
TICKET JUST 16 PERCENT SAY THAT
COUNTRY IS HEADING AND THE RIGH
DIRECTION WHITE WHOPPING 75
PERCENT OR SAY WERE ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
IT HAS BEEN 70 PLUS FOR SEVEN
MONTHS FOR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PUSHBUTTON
ISSUES THAT HAVE PEOPLE
INFURIATED.
CAN GET THE ANXIETIES THAT
AMERICANS OUR FEELING OVER
INFLATION, HIGH GAS PRICES, AND
IT'S REALLY BUBBLING UP.
>> YOU SEE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS A 40 PERCENT APPROVAL RATIN
AMID 55 PERCENT DISAPPROVE, THI
IS A HUGE WARNING SIGN FOR
DEMOCRATS, TO GET IT'S DO OR DI
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THEIR
STARTS, YOU WOULD SAY THESE
VITAL SIGNS ARE VERY BAD.
>> PEOPLE ARE JUST REALLY
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON.
THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE ANYONE CAN
HELP THEM.
THEY TRIED IT WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN THAN THEY
SWITCHED, THEY HANDED POWER TO
THE DEMOCRATS AND NOW INFLATION
HAS GONE RAMPANT AND PEOPLE ARE
UNHAPPY WITH THEIR LIVES.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT'S A FAIR
SUMMATION.
39 PERCENT.
IT'S VERY BAD AND PEOPLE ARE
SLEEP.
WE KNOW JOE BIDEN DIDN'T SEE AN
OF THIS COMING, HE DIDN'T SAY I
WAS POSSIBLE TO WRECK A
FUNCTIONING ECONOMY AND JUST A
YEAR IN A HALF.
BUT THE SIGNS WHERE THEY ARE.
THE NATION'S MONETARY SUPPLY HA
GROWN DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
SPENDING, BUT JOE BIDEN IGNORED
THOSE WHITE WARNING SIGNS, HE
WAS LASER FOCUSED ON DEMONIZING
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS INSTEAD
OF MANAGING THE ECONOMY.
IN A SINGLE BILL THE AMERICAN
RESCUE ACT, BIDEN SPENT
$19 TRILLION ACCORDING TO AN
ARTICLE BY THE FEDERAL RESERVE
BANK OF SAN FRANCISCO, THAT
ACTION LED DIRECTLY TO INFLATION
.
ESTIMATES SUGGEST THAT THE
FISCAL SUPPORT MEASURES DESIGNE
TO COUNTERACT THE SEVERITY OF
THE PANDEMIC ECONOMIC EFFECT MA
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THIS BY
RAISING INFLATION THREE
PERCENTAGE POINTS BY THE END OF
2021.
LET'S, JOE BIDEN KEPT GOING.
HE SPENT ANOTHER TRILLION
DOLLARS ON INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
RESULT?
THE HIGHEST INFLATION RATE WE
HAVE SEEN IN DECADES.
>> THIS MORNING AMERICA SEEMS
TRAPPED IN A VORTEX OF BAD
ECONOMIC NEWS.
SOARING RENTS, UP 16 PERCENT IN
ONE YEAR, COVID LOCKDOWNS IN
CHINA, THE WORLD'S MANUFACTURIN
CENTER, CHOKING THE GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN, U.S. CORPORATE
PROFITS SINKING.
UKRAINIAN WHEAT EXPORTS AT A
STANDSTILL, AND ALL OF IT OF 40
YEAR HIGH INFLATION THAT
AMERICANS OUR PLAYING FOR EVERY
DAY.
TO GIVE YOUR WONDERING HOW ALL
OF THIS GOT JOE BIDEN BY
SURPRISE, CONSIDERING WHO IS
SUFFERING THE MOST HERE.
SOME PEOPLE HIT HARDEST BY THE
ECONOMIC POLICIES AREN'T IN
URBAN AREAS LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
OR NEW YORK, WHICH ARE SOLIDLY
BLUE, JOE BIDEN'S FACE ISN'T
BEARING THE BRUNT OF THIS, HIS
BUBBLE IS SUFFICIENTLY INSULATED
.
THE PEOPLE SUFFERING THE MOST
OUR IN REMOTE RURAL AREAS IN
SMALL TOWNS, TOWNS LIKE MIDLAND
TEXAS.
PLACES THAT ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
CONSERVATIVE.
IT'S A LOT HARDER TO VERY
SUFFICE INTO A PLACE LIKE
MIDLAND BECAUSE IT SO FAR FROM
URBAN CENTERS.
WE WENT TO MIDLAND THAT HAS THE
HIGHEST INFLATION RATE AND THE
COUNTRY AT ROUGHLY 10 PERCENT.
>> PEOPLE IN THIS WEST TEXAS
TOWN SAY IT'S HITTING THEM
HARDEST.
>> WE ARE SOMEWHAT ISOLATED
BETWEEN EL PASO AND DALLAS-FORT
WORTH, AND SO THAT'S A LOT OF
DISTANCE AND IT TAKES YOU FOUR
OR FIVE HOURS TO GO TO EITHER
ONE.
SO TRAVEL COST, TRANSPORTATION
COST, THAT RAISES PRICES.
THEY HAVE A POPULATION OF JUST
OVER 140,000, BUT IT'S GETTING
BIG CITIES RUN FOR THEIR MONEY
WHEN IT COMES TO INFLATION.
HAS THE HIGHEST RATE AND THE
COUNTRY FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
OVER THE LAST WEEK, THE NUMBER
OF FAMILIES.
>> MOST OF THE CLIENTS WE SERVE
27 PERCENT OF THEM HAVE NEVER
NEEDED ANY FORM OF PUBLIC
INSTITUTE BEFORE, THEY ARE READ
GONE UP WHERE THEY CAN'T KEEP U
WITH THE OF GROCERIES.
THEY CAN'T KEEP UP WITH THE COS
OF FUEL PER.
>> THOSE ARE MY PEOPLE IN WEST
TEXAS.
THESE ARE THE UNITY STRATEGY.
AMERICANS, UNITED IN BEING POLAR